oh absolutely and i put my signature
flower on there too just to make it my
own
um it gives it such a lovely kick i love
it
thank you so much it's so amazing oh i'm
so glad you guys said it to me
obviously we're here on the podcast i
would love
i'd be honored to come on your very big
hit
podcast obviously with zach braff and
donald faison
and we're about to surprise a scrubs fan
who credits the show with helping her
become
the doctor that she is today and she
actually thinks that she's here to talk
about the shows that inspired them
to get into medicine but zach and donald
if it's okay
we're gonna hide you okay all right you
guys hide
and then we're gonna um bring in uh dr
jean
roby okay here we go we'll see you in
one second all right i'm gonna tell her
i'm an uber fan
all right please welcome dr gene
roby
[Applause]
hi doctor gene roby it's so nice to meet
you
oh that's so great i feel like i'm in
the room with
oh a giant do you mean the giants on my
onesie
it's donald you really got dressed up i
did well i heard that you were a huge
scrubs fan and that
influenced your life and i'm a giant
scrubs fan
and i'm like just crazy for the show so
i thought
i wanted to ask you like how the show
has had the biggest impact on your life
as a doctor
i i swear that show mattered more than
anything i could think back of during
training
uh jd's internal dialogue turks
slickness
elliot's neuroticism laverne's moral
compass
dr cox's hard truths even um
kelso i i love them all and i'm
literally the doctor i am today with all
my wackiness
and big heart because of scrubs
oh dr jean i love that so much oh wait
hold on
oh wait hold on i gotta page somebody um
we're paging doctors jd
and turk jd and turk are you there
[Applause]
starting with me let's go oh my god
gene oh this is not good hugging us
get in the hud gene yes okay
oh yeah
[Applause]
oh my god i love this so
much by the way it should have been in
studio i also think
by the way maybe when this is all safe
and you're gonna actually be the one to
tell us
uh dr roby when that is we could
all uh have a hangout and we could all
wear these pajamas together
and have a pajama party worth it totally
oh my god this is amazing i i can't
stand it
thank you so much for what you said by
the way that that i can't tell you how
much that means to dial tonight it
really brings a giant smile to our
our faces and our hearts what kind of
medicine did you wind up going into
um i actually left surgery
turk and went to medicine
the very year jd uh started his
internship
and and so sorry church i i left surgery
because of jd
wait let me get this straight you think
my name is turk yeah
i mean that wasn't right
you know what i'm not going to kill the
fantasy you got it
i mean this is this is my fantasy right
like this
i mean i got drew and i got you guys
i mean i don't know i don't know what
else i'm like elliot i'm elliot
yeah okay
um you know uh zach and donald have
actually
talked about the fact that the i heart
radio people
in uh lou of the success of this
podcast you know fake doctors real
friends
are talking about going on tour so maybe
you and i can go
and meet them and like see a show yeah
i can't stop my whole life is going to
be structured around these two guys
and you and uh reminiscing scrubs
it's been the only levity during the
pandemic
it has literally gotten me through
wearing three masks
and dealing with life and death i i
can't stand it
wow well you're a hero you know that
right thank you so much you are a hero
and
we we you it's very sweet that you're
you're saying such nice things to us but
i think
i think i can say on behalf of all three
of us we we want to bow down to you and
thank you
and and all the frontline workers for
for all the insane
uh danger you're putting yourselves in
and how you're
you're the superheroes you're the
superheroes well all of us
uh really kept it together
uh because we could laugh at ourselves
and
we could have something to laugh about
uh so honestly you guys are artists and
really we owe
a lot of how do we get up every day and
do it all over again
to your artistry so thank you so much
thank you so dr much
i'm gonna i'm gonna get you this schwag
clearly
and so we can wear it together and then
maybe we can be in the front row of the
live show
like a couple of crazies yeah i just
love you dancing in it look at her
i'm so happy right now that you're
dancing around with that oh my god it's
such a pleasure by the way
super comfortable dr jean i think you're
gonna be really happy with this i'm
wearing them i'm wearing the scrubs
oh yeah exactly and we're going to be
wearing one season we're going to come
to your live show
um zach donald dr roby thank you
thank you thank you
you